from the northeast to the northwest vast
swathes of england
are under sanction new covid19
infections are rising the virus
could be doubling as fast as every seven
days
there's no question as i've said for for
several weeks now that
we could expect and we are now seeing uh
a second wave
uh coming in i think anybody wants to go
into a second lockdown but clearly
uh you know when you look at what is
happening you've gotta you've gotta
wonder whether
we need to go further than the uh the
rule of six that we brought in
on monday so we'll be looking at uh the
the local lockdowns we've got in
large parts of the country now looking
at what we can do to intensify
things that here in preston more
restrictions are to come into force
to add to the ones already in place
this is a university city thousands of
new students should be enjoying the
start of an academic year
but instead of welcoming freshers the
university has spent the summer
drawing up a covered outbreak response
i would say everybody would be worried
about the potential for a national
lockdown
we just need to keep monitoring the
virus and of course that's why these
regulations have been brought in and i'm
confident as long as we adhere to them
then hopefully we'll be able to avoid it
the r number might be as high as 1.4
and now lancashire merseyside warrington
have all been added to a growing list of
areas
of intervention test and trace was
supposed to help us
avoid another national lockdown but
there were real problems with capacity
in the system and with infection rates
rising not just here
in lancashire but across the country
some other
urgent action is going to be needed
this unchecked rise in infections has
raised the possibility
of a two-week national lockdown in
october
a so-called circuit breaker to slow down
the spread of the potentially
deadly disease i think you may need to
have a more dramatic approach to stop
this i think that the 10 pm curfews
may have worked earlier but i think now
you're seeing
these clusters spreading getting bigger
more people being hospitalized from
these clusters
and the coalescing of all these clusters
together so within a few weeks you might
actually end up with a national
outbreak like the first wave what's gone
wrong with testing ms harding
the head of test and trace dido harding
told mps modelling had failed
to predict the demand for testing but
newly published details of meetings
held by the government scientific
advisory group
seems to contradict that claim the group
said
there are risks associated with opening
further education
higher education settings where
transmission within these institutions
may spill over into the community and
has the potential
to drive outbreaks university campuses
should now be
buzzing with excited young adults on the
cusp of a new life
instead many of them like the rest of us
will be looking nervously ahead
as the specter of a full lockdown
threatens to disrupt
all our lives again ashish joshi
sky news preston